we're really in a way trying to create
an environment that attracts the
smartest people and one of the ways to
do that is to create a culture and an
environment that looks inevitable five
years from now or 10 years from now not
today
a big part of Star Trek is always being
able to predict ahead what's going to
happen and that's all about physically
modeling real-world systems basically
the world is this incredibly rich and
complex place with all sorts of very
very interesting complicated things
happening around us and it turns out
that you can sort of find astonishingly
simple models and then allow people not
only to see but also to interact with
these kinds of phenomena and reopen you
can imagine at building computer
programs which have good reduced
dimensional models of the airflow around
an airplane and controlling and
therefore being able to have building
much much better controllers for a
helicopter for an airplane as me that or
for a spaceship going at work speed
Carnegie Mellon turns out to be one of
the top research centers in the United
States for humanoid robots there is a
lot of very interesting work on
developing social robots robots that
reliably evoke a motional response of a
particular type from the person the
first thing we're going to look at is
how to make characters and robots really
interactive and that means that there
might not be a puppeteer in the
background actually choosing what
behaviors the character would do but
instead it would really be measuring and
responding to the audience there's a
general idea that's in Star Trek of that
bones uses which is this weird sensor
and you just wave over a person you so
you know what's wrong with them so my
research is basically creating
analytical methods to help physicians
and biologists make their decisions
based on data ideally it'll be some sort
of thing that you have in your hand that
will say yes this patient is at high
risk for organ failure or something very
severe like like that in given that
information the doctor will take that
into consideration and make an
appropriate choice for treatment
electronics if it's successful I think
we'll create a new form of communication
and so in Star Trek in the way the
communication is kind of mundane you can
talk through your communicator you can
do video but if you want to be there
face to face you have to go through this
big hassle of actually going there the
idea behind programmable matter is that
you have some stuff like let's say a
pile of sand that has computational
power and you can download a program to
that stuff and as it computes it changes
its shape or some other physical
property you'd have a pile of patrons in
your office that have a pile of petron
it's in my office and you would sort of
your 3d model would get assembled in my
office and my 3d model get assembled in
your office and we'd be able to interact
as if we were there
imagine artwork that understands your
gaze and your physicality and reacts
accordingly and you have the basic
building block of holodeck the new
research are doing involves eyes and how
people use them and in particular I'm
interested in sort of asking the
questions you know what if an artwork
was aware how it was being looked at
what if it could respond to how it was
being looked at with let's say eyes in
its own using in other words a physical
language that people could understand
what science needs more than anything
else is grand challenges and ridiculous
ideas an acute constant stream of them
and I those very much come from science
fiction I think that the the key thing
about something like Star Trek and its
influence on science is that if you're
willing to suspend disbelief and say you
know what let's say it is possible and
start from that point of view it's
really about just sort of you know
stimulating your imagination and start
thinking about the various possibilities
and you know their number of scientists
even in at Carnegie Mellon whom you feel
like they've never lost that sort of
sense of play
you